hey welcome to the DLM model lifestyle
I'm Nikita-Joien. hey guys I'm Daniel and in
this video we're gonna show you how to
do male model poses with suits, so let's
not waste any more time. let's start
hey
guys welcome back! so after you watched
this video please remember to go and
have a look at Daniel's other video
where he explains how to do a photo
shoot for beginners because that video
gives you the basics of how to pose, how
to use your angles and turn different
ways for the camera. yeah that's the
basics and it's called the male model
poses for beginners. so in this video
we're gonna focus just on the suit
itself. so the first thing that you
really need to know is: it's more about the
feeling than it is about the poses.
alright? so you can do the poses all you
want, but you know it's gonna look really
weird if the whole feeling is not there.
right? yeah, so it is also important to
remember that when you do a photoshoot
like this for suits then there are either one
of two ways that the client would want
you to pose: first would be in a very
elegant and very
confident way to showcase the
suit especially for something elegant
like this. but then the other way that
they would maybe want you to pose is
the more relaxed feeling. that's usually
the suits that you were with some nice
sneakers where you also don't wear a tie
so it depends on what the client wants
and what the brief is of the job, right Daniel?
yeah yeah so mostly the clients want you
to have an elegant gentleman, but
strong and confident kind of a look so
that's what you have to give them and to
do that you give them 45 degrees to the
left to the camera to the right and you
give them these angles where you stand
up straight no slouchy kind of you poses.
see how this looks... it just looks like
blegh.. yeah so you stand up straight. Now then
with the poses there's a few things you
can do if you don't know what to do with
your hands: put one hand in the pocket
all right the other one you can put it
here inside your jacket like
you're taking out your phone or
something
or you can check your watch a little bit
or you just look around a little bit
look to the left, look down, look up. all
these kind of poses come and play together
but what you have to try and focus on is
you have to be the person that is in
that suit. so imagine that you're at the
office or if you're at an event. yeah and
another thing that's also good is if the
photographer maybe doesn't have any
props or something with them you can
also use your own initiative to think of
something for example what does look
good on a very professional confident
businessman. It is something like a
briefcase or a kind of coffee those take-away
cups, a newspaper. so if the
photographer doesn't have something like
that or the clients maybe ask them:
listen do you have a magazine or do you
have a newspaper because that also gives
that little bit more of the effect of
the businessman look, the
confidence yeah. yeah especially if
you're doing a test photo shoot, but if
you're gonna work for the client then
they're gonna have their own ideas
already in place so you just you just go and
you do the photo shoot
but apart from that there's three things
that you need to remember as well and
that is the distance that a photographer
is away from the model right if they're
sorry go on
they usually shoot three different ways:
they shoot the full body, which is
usually in landscape and might also be
sometimes in portrait then they
usually photo shoot half body
which is a little bit zoomed in more
and then they also shoot up close because
they want to get the details of the
things like the color or the shirts
and then with the full body they want to
give a little bit more: the pants how
they look, the shoes, etc. So
always remember when photographers
standing a little bit further away they
are usually shooting full-body. okay. then
when they are a little bit closer or when you see
them do their hands like this you know
okay they are zooming in a little bit more
yeah and then if they do zoom in a lot
your expressions are very very very
important
if it's far away then your whole body
all the movements are important. now some
models when they start they struggle
because now they think of their hand so
they forget about the positions of their
feet or you know... so with experience you
will get there. so I'm going to show you
a few examples of walking so you can
just see how that's done
so sometimes you walk straight to the
camera or you walk straight
45 degrees left or 45 degrees to the
right. now for me as experienced model
there's something else I do: so I start
in one direction but I kind of walk in a
kinda  arch as well
because that just makes it more
interesting and more real as well
and then while you're walking don't
just look at the camera all the time
look left, look down,  make
it more interesting. the more variety you
can give to the client the better model
you will be
okay guys and also remember that when
you do the walking poses always have
the leg that is the closest to the
camera that leg needs to be straight
yes yes the other one
bent. if you see the photographer
shoots a little bit closer so it's a
half length and she gets the top of your
legs in the shot, then you can turn
your legs around because then it looks a
little bit more interesting and it gives
it that feeling of more movement but
apart from that the best poses are
actually the poses that you're not
posing at all where it is standing and
looking somewhere or walking and looking
somewhere those shots are the natural
nice shot
the posing shots yes they... you can see
they're very static and very uhh so what you
need to do is basically have your suit
on, it's actually so cool that I've got
mine on today and just do the normal
stand and relaxed poses that you
would when you're in a normal situation
have your color and make it flowy moves
don't move fast or too fast and just move
with the clothes itself. feel the collar
things like that. yeah yeah exactly
alright and just sometimes just forget
about the camera. don't even think about
it because then you look really natural
the days where you do these kind of
poses and you just focus on doing the
poses so good looking unnatural those
days are gone
alright you get it right alright so
those poses you do not want to do just
think naturally walk naturally stand
walk naturally look around naturally
right and when you put your
arms or your hands in your pockets
a lot of the guys that I've seen before
They put the hand in the pocket and
then it crinkles (wrinkles) yeah the jacket yeah yeah.
it messes it up a little bit and it does not look good
in the
video that we did you'll see that
sometimes Daniel puts his hand in his
pocket and then he looks at the jacket
and he straightens the jacket so that's
very important too. if the cameraman and
the client sees that you do things like
that it also counts as brownie points
towards your professionalism because
they can see that you know what you're
doing. yeah 100 percent. a lot of
models forget that it's not just about you
the photo shoot is about the clothes
you're wearing or the product you're
selling so you have to present that in
the best way
right. Test shoots are for the model, that
is where the model needs to look good
but when you do a job, the job is
all about the products remember that
yeah now when it comes to expression you
have to imagine that you're that person
so imagine you're walking in to a
business meeting right now. you have that
confident kind of look. sometimes they
want you to be more friendly more smiley
more inviting, so then you think about
things that make you happy. for me
something I think about my wife.
yes she is the photographer and she is also my
wife so it's like double points for me
anyway you get what I'm saying so
imagine that imagine that role it's a
little bit more like acting
and an important tip that I can give
you guys: if there's specifically
photographers watching is remember to
shoot from a little bit of a lower angle
when you shoot suits because the lower
angle gives a more majestic look to
the model as well as the clothes: broader
shoulders, slimmer hips, and slimmer legs
and looks very nice.
alright guys that's
it for this video if you liked it give
it a thumbs up subscribe and we see you
in the next video choose